hello everybody work here outside of the
st. Louis chess club or doing something
that is pretty much as fun as it gets
for us chess players we're gonna be
playing a game of bullet chest which is
basically one of the ways that some
players practice or game will do perhaps
bullets a little bit too quick each of
us will have one minute to play the
entire game i'm here with fun master my
client might reduce yourself i am the
fun master mike klein I realized that
Alejandro's 10 years younger which is a
big advantage in bullet but i do have 12
million chefs calm members on my side so
hopefully that'll even things out a
little bit the entire world can help you
in this one all right let's do it all
right sir so I've seen this tricks like
my that's not I got an open file money
don't play we should be three there's
many more I know theory I know something
else listens around no no I don't theory
already come on hey sexy sweet guarded
and then now I'm now oh you get one okay
I'll take ya
got a pen growing I'm not that scared if
i go here is that you instantly after
this what coming home coming around the
mountain here I don't like your position
I cooked two seconds that cost you the
game let's go anywhere to go I was
responsible for my most embarrassing
moment of my life I'll keep taking stuff
oh that's okay all right why did I take
about a little Marcy will never forgive
yourself I can run away tricky tricky ok
I have to win this one on time but you
can on Julie existence the way you win
you just trade well as y'all so you
would say when you're ahead in material
just straight apologies ok not bad we're
gonna play this one to me that's what
the viewers on about that
here just kidding here emergency
measures time check ah big that one wow
man that was embarrassing I agree earned
it you earned it well it's okay I made
him look bad but ok he's still my friend